welcome back to new rockstars i'm
whitney van laningham and although
episode five of moon knight appeared to
show mark and steven's journey through
the duo in the form of a psychiatric
treatment facility i think we may also
have gotten our very first glimpse of
jake lockley in the flesh this show has
been teasing his appearance in slow
subtle ways since the beginning of the
series and today i'm going to break down
exactly where jake lockley appears in
moon knight fans have been speculating
since the first trailer drop that
although jake lockley didn't appear
anywhere in it his character may be a
surprise reveal at some point this
season in the comics jake lockley is a
rough and tough cab driver with mad
connections to the cd criminal
underbelly and i think that moon knight
is going to draw heavily from his
character in the welcome to new egypt
comic run for this character in issue
number nine of the comics mark explains
to stephen that although the two met in
his childhood he doesn't meet jake until
later on in his life but in the show it
seems like neither mark nor steven have
ever encountered jake despite a number
of clues they're not the only personas
that share the body let's quickly break
down the evidence of lockley's presence
in each of the previous episodes beyond
the foreshadowing of mark's tri-split
reflections doubled shadows and
different costumes in the very first
episode when stephen's boss donna calls
him a rascal and says she didn't know he
had taken a crack at asking out one of
the museum tour guides he replies i
didn't know either my first thought when
i watched this scene was that mark must
have set up the date on steven's behalf
but although you could argue that mark
was just trying to get his buddy steven
laid i'm not sure that mark was actually
the identity who set up the date mark is
clearly still in love with laila and
despite divorcing her and pushing her
away it's obvious that he still cares
about her deeply why would mark want his
body to hook up with a museum tour guide
if he's still in love with his ex-wife
jake's identity wouldn't have an
emotional connection to layla in the
same way that mark would and could have
asked her out while he was in control of
the body when mark blacks out while
fighting those men on the rooftop in
cairo he transitions once again and when
he comes to he's actively stabbing the
older of the two men as he and steven
both accuse each other of brutally
raising the body count it's clear that
neither one of them was responsible for
these particular slangs steven is too
kind and hopeful to straight up murder
people like that and while mark is the
fist of konshu he seems to be more of a
reluctant hero than a willing
participant his main goal is keeping
layla safe from harrow and konchu and
we've heard him plead with stephen to
let him take control of the body in
order to prevent civilian casualties in
contrast the identity shedding blood in
the streets of cairo seems to have no
issue with getting his hands dirty at
the end of episode 4 mark blacks out
once again after being shot and wakes up
in a psychiatric office after fleeing
harrow he finds steven in a hospital
room trapped inside a sarcophagus but
before they run into tower at the
hippogoddis the two moonboys pass yet
another room with a lone sarcophagus
inside this sarcophagus is standing
upright and shaking but unlike when
steven was stuck whoever's inside isn't
screaming to be let out so both of them
pass by without investigating but many
fans including myself began to speculate
that this might be jake because we see
steven and mark get their own separate
physical bodies in the afterlife it
stands to reason that if this is jake he
would have his own body too if moon
knight's third persona was
lock lead inside that red sarcophagus he
could have broken free shortly after
mark and steven met taured possibly
during all the screaming with mark and
steven on the bow of the funerary boat
the guards who found him would think
that they had caught up to mark but jake
would face the consequences for his
escape let's state the physically
obvious neither mark nor steven had cuts
bruises or bandages on their face when
we saw them screaming together at the
end of episode four and in fact after
this we never see either of them that
beat up again even when steven wakes up
in harrow's office later on in the
episode he doesn't appear to have a
scratch on him and when oscar isaac's
beat up persona wakes up in harrow's
office harrow tells him that he's been
starting imaginary fights in the
hospital could jake have attacked the
guards who tried to return him to harrow
causing them to beat him is that why he
has the bandage on his nose in the
comics jake lockley is not the one who
wears a bandage on his nose during the
welcome to new egypt run mark spectre is
but mark does receive his broken nose
from a couple of guards who assault him
and force him to undergo electroshock
therapy in issue one when he wakes up
his nose is broken and his eyes are
bruised just like oscar isaacs in this
scene i think that marvel borrowed this
element from the comics and used it as
another way for us to tell the
difference between these three
characters our friends at the epic hero
shop have some of the coolest t-shirts
in merch when the thor love and thunder
trailer dropped they asked us for some
help with zooming and enhancing and were
able to recreate the trucker hat that
thor wears during his training montage
and you can get one for your very own
training montage they have a new
spider-man no way home shirt with peter
parker's face and who the hell is this
it's both clever and the only one of its
kind a very cool shirt to wear to the
theater to see multiverse of madness
would be the wanda variant of the
unusual couple shirt it's an augmented
reality shirt so you can use your phone
to unlock a video layer on the shirt
they've got all kinds of great marvel dc
and star wars inspired gear at
epicuroshop.com
sign up for their newsletter at the
bottom of their webpage to get notified
about merch drops be your own hero but
besides that this person also sounds
slightly different than mark to me
although he only speaks a couple of
words at a time at the beginning of his
talk with harrow by the time he speaks
his first full sentence his accent
doesn't sound like mark or stevens not
only does he speak a little bit more
gruffly it also sounds like there's a
twinge of a new york accent here they
always pay you a lot of money in this
place you're really good in the comics
jake is a cab driver from new york so
that could explain the new separate
accent as he says that line we see oscar
isaac grab that sharp pyramid
paperweight and brandish it towards
harrow prompting the doctor to hit the
panic button to call his guards notice
the way that oscar isaac scans the room
before grabbing that pyramid as soon as
he realizes that harrow isn't a doctor
not only does he look around the room
confusedly as if he's never been there
before he quickly grabs the pyramid once
he gets his bearings when mark was in
this office in episode four his first
instinct wasn't to outright stab harrow
it was to flee and although steven
throws a glass of water in harrow's face
as soon as he awakens in the office
later in the episode he immediately
apologizes for it like i said earlier if
jake is the most violent out of the
three it would make sense that his
immediate reaction was to fight when the
guards arrive moments later to shoot him
up with what i can only imagine is
liquefied quaaludes it mirrors a scene
in issue 4 of welcome to new egypt after
turning down a sleepover with a nice
lady jake is jumped by two guards with
gigantic needle who assuming he's mark
spector attempt to drag him to the
hospital we don't see oscar isaacs again
with a messed up face in this episode so
if this character is jake lockley he's
still likely back in the hospital wing
of the duo which is actually incredibly
convenient for both mark and steven
despite the beauty of this place in the
afterlife mark doesn't want to be
trapped in the field of reeds and steven
certainly doesn't want to be a frozen
sand sculpture forever if they need help
getting out of the underworld however
they manage to do it it'll be useful to
have a guy on the outside of the dead
world i'm not going to lie there are a
number of ways that this next episode
will go down but there's one thing i'm
fairly confident about when we finally
formally meet jake lockley his third set
of hands are gonna be a crucial part of
stopping harrow and he might be the key
to rescuing either mark stephen or both
from the afterlife follow me on
instagram and twitter whitneypuppy
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you